Stargate is 27 years old happy birthday
welcome to psycheck here Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
it's your birthday we're here to party
and sing to you so this is just a very
quick video to celebrate that Stargate
sg1 is 27 years old today It first aired
in the United States on the 27th of July
1997.
that was when our love affair with
Stargate first began and no this isn't
going to be a long video I just really
wanted to say that but I also wanted to
give you guys an opportunity to get into
the comments tell me some of your
favorite bits from the Stargate Universe
and to really throw in a couple of my
favorites
happy birthday Stargate
I hope you come back soon initial images
portraying this planet as a paradise
seem to have been manufactured and then
broadcast back to us through the mouth
why
possibly with the intended purpose of
luring us into this room
see I knew it was too good to be true
wow This coffee's great
I was just thinking that
yeah is that cinnamon it's chicory
[Music]
isn't that hot
extremely
[Music]
just
stay on the base
too late for what to stop this day from
happening again
you realize this is a little difficult
for me to accept hey if it was just me
I'd agree
but what about tilk
come on is this the face of a crazy man
bad example
Commander Thor
my name is Senator Kinsey
O'Neill suggested I send you to a
distant planet for your actions here but
I am reasonably certain his statement
was ingest I'm sure it was commander
Supreme Commander
in the middle of my backswing so I can
do this
why didn't you let me do it uh I can do
it just uh do me a favor and some help
okay well go to the panel by the rear
exit
okay now what stay there shut up and let
me finish
wow buddy we're just talking about you
all good
I know you are aware of the red potatoes
I bet my fleets has engaged them in
battle
there's been a little chit and chat
around the water cooler
how's that going we're holding them away
for the moment however
they are more formidable Force than I
first anticipated yeah
pesky little buggers aren't they I'm
aware of the desk I'd have previously
fought the replicators effectively
more or less
I don't like to do my own horns I am
aware that you assisted the escon
I wish to know what means you possessed
to fight the scourge
I'm sorry
we must have had a bad connection there
for a second
it almost sounded like you were asking
me for help
the replicators are a threat to everyone
it kind of accomplish humans who
populate worlds throughout this galaxy
now I propose
that we work together to defeat our
common enemy bye
this is an occasion
foreign
[Music]